so Richard Holmes the closure of ticket
officers could make Railways even more
inaccessible he's partially cited and
knows all too well how difficult it can
be when there's no ticket kiosk I find
it a an unusable machine to activate my
ticket so I have to get help from a
family member or a member of staff not
many people guide independently as it is
so this is just another potential huge
variable that we're coming to play
the rail delivery group plans to close
the majority of ticket offices in
England
it says it's all about cutting costs and
modernizing customer service but not all
customers are happy
have a computer at home I can use it but
a lot of my friends haven't got a
computer how do they get their tickets
use the ticket machine have you ever
tried to use one of those ticket
machines there they're awful to use
obviously I get that lots of places
would like to go paperless and things
like that that yeah for the older
generation it's not ideal it's rare on
Young Generation who know how to work
the new technology I don't think it's
fair on on the older Generations without
ticket offices passengers will have to
pay for their Journeys by either buying
tickets online using the self-service
machines tapping their contactless card
on the barriers or by buying tickets
from station staff either on The
Concourse or on the train itself the
government insists this isn't about
cutting jobs but the frustration felt by
Union reps is clear they have to think
about what they what what at further
they can do to protect their jobs and
and livelihoods we our members don't
want to close the booking offices that
they're campaigning to keep open
according to the rail delivery group
ticket officers accounted for 85 of
total sales in the 90s but now they only
sell 12 of tickets transport Minister
Hugh Merriman says the closures will
help with efficiency the people that
work in ticket offices are not being
properly utilized so we want to give
them a more rewarding job out on the
platform in the station interacting with
all passengers there's no doubt it's a
significant change and for some it's
going to make traveling by train that
bit more difficult I shazard Sky News